[Music]
on today's show we talk about hard adult
topics so be very careful about the
little ones in the room listening to
this one
this show involves three women three
wonderful moms trying to navigate really
messy situations with their husbands
their ex-husbands
or the father of their kids for husbands
and wives listening to this show
pay close attention stay tuned
yo yo yo what's up and welcome to the dr
john dolone show
the show is about you your lives your
messiness the cleanliness the cuts and
bruises and the big
earth-shattering winds all of it right
i've been walking alongside folks
just like you for almost two decades
whether your life is rocking onto the
break of dawn
or your life is teetering on the edge of
disaster
or you are sitting in a pile of ash
trying to figure out what to do next
everything around you is burned down and
you don't know what's next
i've been there i've seen it and i've
committed my life to walking alongside
people like you
trying to figure out that dude in the
mirror here i'm trying to help people
re-learn how to be people again how to
live how to interact with each other
right
how to stop the anxious depressive
nonsense
madness and how to be calm okay
with who we see in the mirror and if
you're new to our band of ninjas we talk
about everything on the show
mental health challenges family and
relational iq questions
schooling education concerns parenting
addiction marriages
and we may talk about people who ride
three wheel motorcycles listen
here's the deal switzerland this is
america
and i'm not drinking the haterade you do
you if you listen to the show you know
i support most people most of the time
but you mid-life crisis guys with your
motorized tricycles
all leathered up trying to be all hard
here's the thing you're
super not dudes pick a side i've never
seen
a young cool person on a motorized
tricycle all leathered out like what's
up with their hair slicked back
listening to social distortion that
would be awesome
it doesn't exist i've never seen like
any woman ever if you're a woman who
drives a motorized tricycle holler
backer will let me
even if you ain't no hollerback girl
call me because i want to know if you
exist right
but listen gentlemen pick a side
car or motorcycle and if your first
thought is i just like riding but i
don't feel comfortable
on two wheels that's the universe saying
ride a horse or get a car
that's it pick a side we're drawing the
line 20 21
pick aside so that's it all right so
here's the deal whatever's going on in
your life
if you know somebody who's a three wheel
motorized tricycle rider what i don't
even know how to call those things
motorcycle motor try cycles i don't even
know dude
i'm sure there's a thing give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show
fill out the form it goes right into
kelly's mailbox
and then we will see if we can have you
on the show that would be awesome before
we get on it i gotta let you know this
happened
is super funny crack me up um yesterday
my family me and my wife and my son and
daughter were hiking
and we came to a fork in the road and i
was trying to be cool that an adventure
dad my kids are all into dragons and
whatever star wars and shenanigans so i
got down on one knee and
i had both kids on either side of me and
i said this is the fork in the path
choose your next steps wisely one of
these roads
leads to greatness and the other road
leads to certain doom
and without missing a beat my daughter
looks up at my son with her eyes all
wide and she goes
let's choose the path of certain doom
because i want to watch the destruction
and i looked at my wife and i was like
dude i didn't learn about that in
counseling classes
that doesn't exist i think my daughter
is either going to be one of those
people who listens to lots of serial
podcasts
about murderers or she will become one
right so
either way it's awesome so we're all
today today on the show we are taking
the path of certain doom i hope not i
hope we're going to take the positive
path of greatness but
let's go to the phones let's go to
heather in salt lake city utah
heather good afternoon how in the world
are you
i'm good thank you for taking my call
today thank you so so much for calling
so
what's going on how can i help um i have
i have primary custody of my
nine-year-old son and
he has an unhealthy relationship with
his dad
so i was wondering if it is ever morally
acceptable to terminate or limit
visitation between them
there are seasons there are moments
there are situations where
absolutely um you've got to
get between your son and somebody who's
hurting them or somebody's putting them
in a bad environment
and be the person who's responsible for
them right and so you terminate
whatever relationships you've got to
terminate in fact
um one of the chief mentors in my life
um growing up learning counseling
learning psychology
she was responsible for terminating
parental rights in utero before kids
were born and so
yeah there's absolutely a place for that
but before we go there
back me up tell me about this
relationship with an unhealthy
relationship with your
between your son and his dad
um he's had a history with like opioid
addiction
um he'll go months without
you know seeing my son especially you
know in the first
like five six years of his life um
like six months at a time sometimes
my son will you know call him and call
him and call him and he won't
he won't answer or won't return his
calls that sucks
and i am i've been married
you know for five years
now and as he gets closer to my husband
my son's dad does not like that and
it's gotten to a point where he
will try telling lies you know about me
and about my husband
and my son will say you know i don't
believe that
and recently he started saying well if
you don't believe it then
you know i'm just going to let him adopt
you and i'm never going to see you again
and he did this over christmas and
several weeks without you know he hung
up on my son after saying that and went
several weeks without
talking to him so my son was devastated
and
you know he believes him when he says
these things and
it's just does he know that his daddy's
sick
and i know there's a character moral
here but i'm i'm trying to use a
language that a nine-year-old can
understand
does he know that daddy's sick yeah um
i try not to say and i don't want him to
think negatively about his dad sure you
know i don't want him to take that on
himself and listen
that's noble and i think that's that's
the right way to approach this
but there is a reality to it also right
so you can
say something like your daddy's a piece
of crap
and he's a loser and he's a drug addict
don't listen anything he says
you can say that and that's running his
daddy down
and i know in your heart that's what you
want to say right you want to just
sit down and look at your son and say
let me tell you about this dude the
other side of it
is you can tell your son daddy's sick
and sometimes the words and his thoughts
get jumbled up and they come out in ways
that sound really mean
he's not trying to hurt you he would
never hurt you intentionally
um but sometimes he says things that
just aren't right
that just aren't true because he's not
doing well and that's a totally
different approach
if you don't say something like that
you're right your nine-year-old will
begin
he's gonna internalize it anyway but
he's gonna have no fallback plan so he's
gotta have somebody in his life which
that's you
saying those things aren't true right
yeah and i have i've told him
you know he's just not he's not healthy
right now
and i said you know and sometimes when
people aren't healthy they don't really
know how to
show love in the way that they're
supposed to oh that's hey that's
beautiful heather you're doing great
you're doing great and we we're getting
into counseling
good well um right now my attorney is
suggesting that
you know that we at the very least
limit visitation i think
i think that's as wise as possible um it
doesn't sound like your
your son's dad is in any place to be a
parent
and if he is still a functioning addict
then your son's not safe
emotionally your son's not safe
psychologically your son's not safe
in person right um is is he
missing appointments is he keeping up
with child support is he doing those
things or no
oh no he he's been
consistently behind on child support
person's entire life
um our son has had a really extensive
medical
history resulting in like over 20
surgeries and just oh
man you know he has caused him to miss
really important
doctors and appointments just out of
spite he decided to just keep him from
me
so hey heather you know the answer to
this
so why are you calling why are you not
secure in your
answer and you're what you know the
right thing to do is
i just i didn't have i
i'm sorry no you're good i didn't have a
health i didn't have a relationship with
my dad and
my son's father also didn't i've just
tried
okay but listen this relationship listen
your son doesn't either
no he doesn't right and so trying to
force feed one together trying to
duct tape something together is just
hurting your son
and i know that you know that right tell
me about this
tell me about your your husband
he's he's been in my son's life since he
was about three
and it was very slow process
you know getting my son's just always
a mama's boy you know yeah of course i
was the only one
that he ever really had yeah and you're
the only stable one there that's exactly
right
so but tell me about this guy is he a
good guy he's a good husband oh yeah
yes he is we have you know three other
boys now and
you know he's he's an awesome dad he
you know he loves my son as his own
he reached out you know wanting to adopt
him he just said you know
i would like to step up i'd like to
adopt him if
you don't want that i understand but if
you don't want that i need you to step
up
good for him dude you married well look
at you heather
well i mean it really caused a lot of
retaliation at first he agreed to it
he's like yes let's go through with this
adoption
we were going to start the process and
then
my son's dad ended up telling my son
about it and
i don't know if he gently did this or
how he went about it but
probably not because the guy the guy's
sick man the guy is sick
he's he is talking through
yeah he's talking through an opioid
filter and he's not
um he's not being the dad he's supposed
to be
and so here's the thing i'm gonna do
something i don't normally do i'm not
gonna give you an answer because
you already know what to do heather you
already know what to do what you've got
to do is
let the fantasy of your son and this
magical dad go
it's not going to exist it's not there
your son's dad has taken
great gone through great lengths to make
sure
that he's not well he has made some
significant
choices in his life to make sure that
he's not going to be connected to his
son
and he's using his son as weapon and as
a weapon and as leverage
and he is tethered to this kid in a way
that the kid is drowning because
dad is underwater do i want to give up
on dad no but that's not something that
you can solve you're in a new marriage
in a new relationship
and dad has chosen to not be a father
and the the the
fairy tale of this particular story
heather you married a stud you married a
rock star
who loves you and who had enough courage
to go to this boy's um i'm not going to
call him a
a dad go to this boy's father and say
hey i'm about to step up and do the
right thing here unless you do
and then you're the debate you know your
son's dad was like
your son's father was like okay go ahead
man ridiculous
dude you are in a great situation you
actually have an opportunity for your
son to have a father
and have a dad right have somebody who's
connected to him raises him as his own
four boys running a muck in your house
and you can untether yourself from this
loser once and for all
my hope my deepest hope is this dude
gets connected to a rehab program
gets his head screwed on straight does
the hard hard work
of going to a group for year after year
and getting sober and getting clean
and then doing the hard humble groveling
on his
face work of coming back into your son's
life and saying i
screwed up i sucked i used you
son as leverage and a tool to hurt your
mom because i was sick and i'm sorry
and that's years away and that's not
going to happen now it's not going to
happen tomorrow
what can happen now what can happen
tomorrow is
you knew what the right thing is you've
got experts you've got professionals in
your life saying
whoa we got to step in you know that's
the right thing to do
and you got an awesome guy ready to be a
dad
to your little boy so thank you so much
for the call
you are doing all the right things
heather
you just gotta kill the fantasy let the
fantasy be absolutely gone let it
poof like a vapor like frozen two i
don't even know how frozen two ended but
if it ended like a vapor i want you to
end it like that otherwise
um go for it you're in the right place
doing the right thing good for you
heather
all right let's go to uh molly in coeur
d'alene
idaho molly what's happening how are we
doing
hi i'm doing all right thank you so much
for talking with me thank you for
calling thank you for calling hey
before we get going give me a like a
weather report of idaho
i'm down here in the south how's idaho
well we just had over a foot of snow
over the weekend on new year's and it
has
slowly been melting and we're gonna get
more snow next week all right that
sounds like idaho okay very cool
all right so what's going on molly how
can i help
so yeah i do need some help um my
husband
i love him i know he loves me but he is
very vocal and feels that
he works much harder than me in pretty
much all aspects of our lives
he has refused to talk to a marriage
counselor he's even threatened
divorce because he feels that i'm not
working hard enough in
um again all aspects of our life
including parenting and so i don't
really know what to do
since i've tried talking to him and i've
tried marriage
like offering marriage counseling i've
seen a counselor myself
so molly what does he want you to do
um what's he like when he sits down like
when he sits down and looks at you
what does he like list out because this
sounds like one of those idiots
is a list maker what is the list he's
putting out there that you're not living
up to
um the list it's everything so
everything from
um just house chores so laundry dishes
um down to finances you know and paying
bills
um to parenting um about how we're
raising our two daughters
and what i'm not doing correctly
according to
him um and it's it's difficult because
you can tell that he doesn't talk about
things he waits until he's frustrated
about something and then he kind of just
blows everything up all at once what is
your intimate life like
um it's off and on depending on these
blow ups
okay so we'll go about two weeks and
everything's
great we're intimate we're smiling we're
laughing
and then all of a sudden there's
something on his list
like this week it's laundry um
so what did you do what did you do what
did you do wrong with the laundry molly
like how did you according to him i work
so i work 40 hours a week um we have two
daughters and
he works out of town okay and so when he
comes home at the end of the week
um i don't have all the laundry folded
because i work 40 hours a week and i'm
taking care of our two daughters it's
ridiculous
that's ridiculous i'm just kidding go
ahead so
but yeah when he comes home it's not
done and he's he gets very vocal about
how there's too many clothes
that aren't clean or put away so anytime
somebody
whether it's a friend of mine whether
it's myself
whether it's um somebody in this
situation like on the radio or
an old counseling client my first
question is always this
is he right
um he does have some grounds for some of
it absolutely
and i do vocalize yeah the laundry is
not folded
that's silly right so like the the
actual nuts and bolts
right that's i mean those are
checklist things those aren't those
aren't
roots those aren't virtues right i'm
talking less about
because those type of nitpicky things
are are a coward's way of saying
you're not the wife that i want or
you're not living up to this
imaginary fictional human that i've got
in my head
or they are have delusions of grandeur
so they're off doing their job
and quite honestly they're probably
really busy they're probably exhausted
fill in the blank
probably not as tired as a 40-hour week
single mom at home with two kids
um but tired nonetheless and they come
home
and they get on the airplane or they get
in their car and they have this fantasy
of what the home's gonna look like
and then that picture doesn't match the
picture in their head and then they
throw a temper tantrum
and so that's i'm talking about the
virtue part here
that's he's saying you are not the
partner
that i was hoping for and you are not
living up to the partnership that we
agreed on or that i'm demanding and so
my first
question always is is he right
are you a self-sabotaging wife or are
you somebody who's not interested in
having a partnership with him are you
um getting home from work and just
saying i'm not doing nothing
forget all this like is that is there
accuracy there
no absolutely not all right cool so
before i go after somebody
then i just want to i want to get that
part out of the way because here's a
great example
i had a i was not a great boyfriend in
college
and though i was dating somebody who's
now my wife and
um we got into a tiff and i came home
i'll never forget this i walked into my
house and there was it was
this wacky apartment on top of a
building downtown and
i walked in and my buddies were watching
tv or whatever and i said something
along the lines of
this girl who's now my wife said i was a
jerk and or i was an idiot or whatever
can you believe that and then my buddy
trevor
who's still to this day one of my best
friends on planet earth
goes are you being serious you're like
the biggest jerk i've ever met
and i was like what i thought i was the
kindest guy and he's like
no are you being for real and so i was
in that moment
right in a moment of reflection um
by the way everybody needs honest
friends like that that's why i still
love him
is because he was right you know i had
to look in the mirror and say
no i i am i'm not handling these things
right but you have done that and it's
not you
right correct okay so
what's your what's your ultimate
question you've got you're in a
situation now you can't win
you've got somebody who's got delusions
of grandeur you've got somebody who has
made it their life mission to make sure
you know your place and your place is
going to be below me
in a place where you can't win so and
you've got two daughters who are
absorbing
every second of this and whether they
want to or not
are learning this is what marriage looks
like and this is what a husband who says
quote unquote i love you and your mom
treats how they treat people and so
what's your question
the biggest thing is how do i get him
to understand that marriage counseling
or just
counseling for himself for whatever it
is that's bothering him so much
would help him because you can't come
home and he might be tired
no yeah you can't there's nothing
you can do to make him change
he's gonna have to decide i want to have
a
partnership with my wife that we are
going to become one in this adventure
journey raising kids and being married
and being together
and having a great sex life and a great
communication life and
lots of laughter and as much joy as this
crummy world will give us he's got to
decide that on his own
you can and you've probably done this
and so here's a couple things i'm
rattling off top of my head
you can
have a conversation with him that's not
that's pretense
right um pre blow up pre-fight
pre-frustration you can have that
conversation upstream
um and you've probably heard me say a
thousand times and i'll say it a
thousand times more
you can have a meal and go somewhere you
can go get a bed and breakfast one night
and just get away and tell them that you
want to have a retreat
my wife and i just did that recently to
start the new year we did that every
year we have a retreat
and this year like most years it was
teary we laughed a lot we had to have
some hard conversations with one another
but we're just putting out there we're
just being vulnerable and honest
you may have already done that have you
already had those hard conversations
i've tried to okay they usually don't
they they're usually one-sided usually
i'm the one talking and he
walks away or changes the subject okay
so when you
when you said he's threatened divorce
like an idiot
yeah uh i don't mean to talk bad about
your husband but people are like no i'm
just gonna be
shut up dude so does
does he is he serious about it
um he threatened it once um
a couple weeks ago and he seemed pretty
serious about it
okay and so i kind of let him play that
you know if he wanted if he was that
unhappy i told him
you know i don't want him to be happy so
i let him play through with it
and then of course he realized that he
was an idiot and
um just we had our two weeks of
good relationship where he listened to
me and he apologized
partially to me you know as best that he
knows how to apologize and
and we moved on from that two weeks and
then it
all started over again minus the threats
of divorce
so here's what i want you to do
i want you to work you're in counseling
now you have a therapist now
yes okay i want you to when do you see
your counselor next
um i'm not on the schedule yeah okay i
usually do every two weeks okay
so the next time you go see your
counselor
i want you to show up with a list and i
want you to tell your counselor
today i want to you to help me
solidify and draw firm boundaries
that i'm going to communicate in a hard
conversation with my husband
and what that's going to look like are
things like
you will not threaten divorce in this
house
you will not belittle me in front of my
daughters
if you want something done a certain way
we're going to talk about it and i'm
going to let you know that i want to
honor
you i want to be a great partner here
and you're going to honor me because
sometimes my 40-hour a week job
and one of our two daughters and or both
daughters have some struggles and life
happens
and you're not going to talk to me that
way anymore
because i deserve more i'm worth more
our
daughters cannot watch this nonsense
because i need you to hear me say kids
absorb yelling they absorb that fight
they absorb that tension
and they blame themselves and your
daughters are growing up in a situation
where for the rest of their life they're
going to try to figure out how to make
sure the man in their life
um is doing okay and you know the road
that will put them on
right and this is
a hard reality i understand that i'm not
making light of this this is hard hard
hard hard hard
but the the the hard conversation has to
start with
both of your feet firmly planted on the
floor which means i want you to get with
your counselor and draw these boundaries
out to a t
you will not talk to me that way anymore
period
and here is the way this is going to
look and you're going to have to have an
or what
right in counseling we always talk about
you have to have an or what because he
may say well forget you then
and you're gonna have to have those
boundaries drawn and you're gonna have
to have
your next counseling appointment already
ready to rock and roll but i want you to
begin to put but not begin i want you to
firmly plant both feet on the ground
you've done the hard work of looking in
the mirror and saying is this me or not
and you said no it's not it's
unreasonable i'm being attacked every
day
every couple of weeks the guy in my life
throws a temper tantrum the guy who
swore he's gonna love me and protect my
daughters
chooses to go to war because he's a
grown-up child
and this is gonna be the season that you
say no more 2021 is gonna be the season
that
that you say molly no more you're not
gonna talk to me that way i'm gonna
treat us that way
and so here's what i want you to do have
that conversation with your therapist
have the conversation with your husband
please don't do it in the middle of a
fight
plan it let him know it's coming tell
him that you are still
reeling from the declaration that i want
to divorce
and that you want to follow up with him
about that
and that's when you are going to take a
bold step and say here's who
we are going to be in this house and i
love you and i desperately want to fight
fight fight for this marriage but i'm
not gonna fight myself
and i'm not gonna fight somebody who
keeps turning their back on us so molly
let me know how those conversations go
um we'll be thinking about you those are
hard you're in a hard hard
situation and by the way to everybody
when somebody comes at you
with you're not this you're not
upholding that
you are the worst fill in the blank you
screwed this up you're an idiot
whatever i learned this from
a young employee of mine a decade or
more ago and
i asked him his name is jordan bunch
he's an extraordinary guy he lives in
dallas i think or
somewhere in central texas i'll never
forget i asked him just in passing
here i was i was his boss right and i i
ended up
walking away from that conversation
learning more than i'd learned that year
i
i said man you're always so peaceful
even when when
you're frustrated you're always so
peaceful how do you remain so
at peace in these hard conversations and
these hard moments and he said something
that has stuck with me ever since
he said anytime somebody comes at me
with an accusation they come at me angry
the first thing i do
is i look in the mirror and i ask myself
what am i contributing to this problem
what did i contribute to this
is this right and i thought man what a
great way to approach life
and and not to constantly be blaming
yourself and shaming yourself and taking
over blame like it's probably me no not
that but just stopping for a second and
saying am i being a jerk right and
make sure you've got people in your life
like trevor who i love who will tell you
like my buddy todd like my buddy john my
buddy kevin who will tell you
hey man we don't do that don't be that
guy don't act like that don't say that
you everybody's gotta have people in
their life that will hold them
accountable
and say you're not the one this is not
molly
this is not molly molly's doing right
look in the mirror folks and then you
gotta make hard calls and draw hard hard
boundaries all right let's take one more
call let's go to
amanda in knoxville tennessee
amanda how are we doing i'm doing all
right john how are you
i'm doing all right too i'm doing better
than all right usually when somebody
says
i'm doing all right and they're in the
south that means they're not doing very
good at all
is it am i on the on the right track
yeah you you put it on the bull's eye oh
man okay so what's going on amanda how
can i help
um let's see to give you some background
information
my name is amanda um i am married
me and my husband we've been married for
a little over three years now
we have an 11 month old baby boy um
i i do have some postpartum depression
and postpartum anxiety that i'm dealing
with
um but you did have a baby and a global
pandemic right
yes oh mercy yeah okay
that's the other most southern thing oh
mercy hey
you've earned your postpartum so
man god bless you that's a tough tough
season to have a young one and so
blessings to you all right so go ahead
i found out in early december um
a complete shocker my husband
had improper contact with a minor at our
church
um and i'm having trouble
dealing with the aftermath of that with
the church
with the other family involved
and just moving forward with this
situation
when my husband comes home i'm just i'm
at my wit's end
and i feel like um i
i just i don't know what to do yeah
that's a lot
all right so walk me through some of the
particulars here and this is a highly
sensitive
situation and so you at any moment say i
don't want to talk about that part
okay is that cool sure absolutely
or here's a better way to say it you're
in 100 control of this narrative and so
at any moment
you can bow out okay is that cool yeah
okay so when you say inappropriate
contact with a minor
what does that mean how old what was the
inappropriate contact
walk me through that sure um
the girl is 13 years old i found out
that
he held hands with her at church one
wednesday night
she says no sexual contact happened he
says no
sexual contact happens so
hopefully that not reduces some of this
but i guess it doesn't make it even
harder
um well holding hands on a 13 year old
is sexual contact
um oh okay maybe they didn't touch
it with kids we call it bathing suit
parts right so
like any part that's covered up by a
bathing suit is off limits but
what was the situation where somebody
would how did that
what's the narrative that how they ended
up holding hands
sure um what happened was
um the girl's dad
helps operate the sound booth at our
church
and controls the the tech side and
he wanted to learn how to work it as
well so that way
um not just one person is stuck
doing that and there can be a rotation
and she was back there as well with
with her dad and
she and of course this is no
justification whatsoever it's just me
trying to
gain a remote sense of understanding
um she was kind of making moves at him
um where she was hiding her lips
not a thing not a thing at all
because she's a child don't even go
there in your head okay
don't even go with your head i know you
want to protect your husband and more
importantly you want to protect your
sanity right now
okay yeah i don't care if that 13 year
old
threw herself at him sent him a bunch of
inappropriate pictures i don't care
what that child did the adult in that
situation
is the adult in that situation right
absolutely 100 okay so go ahead
so she she was um
i don't even know what to say she's a
kid he felt as though he was
she was being provocative um
in a sense and then he said that um
he he was just thinking about a former
void
in his teenage life that was unfilled
due to trauma
and he just needed words of affirmation
and a kind touch from a kid
yep
yeah dude
man amanda i don't get mad very often
and
yeah i'm pretty close so what was the
church's response here
um of course um when
when this was found out um we had a
meeting
with the deacons um there there are five
of them at the church
um the girl's parents and then um my
husband was present at the meeting
i was on speakerphone because you know
i'm i
someone has to be home take care of our
son
so the decision was was that
he needed he needed to go to intense
therapy
or the dad was going to immediately go
to the police
and and file a police report and have
you know my husband
go to jail uh you know right rightfully
so for it
so hold on hold on hold on hold on oh
gosh dude man so the church didn't call
the police
they didn't call social worker they
didn't get the authorities involved
no it pisses me off so bad
so bad oh man
amanda i'm sorry uh i'm not sorry i know
my anger's not at you my anger is at
church is covering up stuff like this
which is how it perpetuates and goes on
and on
and on and on and it communicates
to teenagers that adults aren't held
like responsible in the appropriate
nuclear option which is what should
happen in these moments
oh my gosh okay so
man
i'm singing for a second is that cool
amanda oh
sing away i'm sure you sang my mercy too
right
so yeah long story short um my blood
pressure's getting up
and i'm gonna get that uh man i don't
think i've ever gotten
super pissed off on the radio um
maybe i have i don't remember not like
this
um so what's your ultimate question
let's just get to that
sure um well sin since this
has gone on my husband did go to therapy
he checked himself into a place called
the ranch
um it's you know outside of nashville
yeah i know about it and uh so he's
there right now he's in the sex
addiction program
well he a sex addict
uh yes yes so is he a pornography ad
does he have lots of affairs
um he has never had an affair but
uh pornography addiction yes
so he's never had an affair but he
claims he's a sex addict
uh yes so i've heard
the fall to my knees
me i'm so sorry i'm an addict excuse
often in the last decade 20 years
the sex addicts i've known the sex
addicts i've
i have um several of my mentors
and professors were actually like
they were um
they were trained therapists that worked
with people with sexual behavior
disorders
and true sex addicts
man they they they don't have unaffair
it's a way of life it's the way i eat
gummy candies
it's pathological right um
anyway that's not what you called um
i have a hard time believing somebody
and me and maybe there's a medical
doctor out there or a psychologist that
overrides me and they can override me
all day long i'm not going to go to war
with them on that but i have a hard time
signing up for somebody who's a sex
addict who
instead of saying that they're somebody
who made awful terrible disgusting
decisions
and needs to be criminally held liable
for what they're doing
or at the very least not around kids
um yeah yikes okay so he's in rehab now
he's in rehab um because he held hands
with a 13 year old
and is he getting out soon i guess if
this is early december so he's coming
out
next whenever right yeah
by the end of this month okay so can i
can i um
just make a guess here
in the have you all been allowed to
usually there's a few weeks of no
contact and then there's just limited
you know drip by drip contact have y'all
started reconnecting again
uh yes he he gets one 20-minute phone
call every other
day okay so i'm just going to take a
wild guess here
you are not going to believe amanda how
much i've changed
the things i've learned about myself in
my past and my childhood are so big and
so deep and it's
amazing and i can't wait to be around
you and the baby because
everything is clear now i understand
and it's so incredible how much i've
grown and i'm better
am i close yes
like right hitting the nail on the head
oh yeah you're like 99
yeah so what are you gonna do
what do you want to do um
let me let me back up i think you know
exactly what you want to do
i think you're an extraordinary good
person
i think you're a um are you a christian
yes okay so you have a christian ethic
about you you've got a way of
being you've got a picture of what your
marriage and this new little baby was
gonna be how old are you
um i'm 33. okay so you had a you're 33
you've waited for this you've got a
husband who
was participating a guy who helped at
the sound booth in church right so you
had this picture
and now it's an ash right yes
completely and the temptation is to try
to just pick up all this ash in a bucket
and start trying to duct tape it back
together
think of it like the twin towers if they
went and swept up
all that glass and dust and twisted
metal and steel
and tried to rebuild it with that those
materials you can't do it
so any relationship you have with this
dude moving forward
is after this
okay and that is hard to hear i'm i
can't be the first person who's told you
that
but it's hard to hear i know um but
moving forward trying to reclaim this
picture
it is no more okay gotcha
um your church quite honestly let you
down your husband let you down um
the whole thing's a mess and i'm so so
sorry amanda
oh well thank you i know
i didn't help you i know um you know
what you want
what you need to do you know what you
want to do what
just for my own sanity and for the
listeners here
what what do you think the next month
looks like for you
i think in the next month um he'll come
home
and for a few days he will be a
completely
transformed person but then little by
little it'll
revert back and um
it it'll just go back to where it
started
you know just you know any kind of
progress is just
unraveled because you know he he gives
me a whole list of things that he wants
to change and
and everything and how life wants to be
and
he's going to follow the 12 steps to a t
and um
i have a feeling that being out in the
real world
that he'll he will real like recognize
how
hard that actually is and um
i don't know if he's if he's up for the
challenge of
making such a huge change in his life
you know for for such a long period of
time because it
you know it that would be a hard thing
to even attempt to
you know cut come back from i mean
there's so much depth to it from from
what i'm understanding and so i
i just have a feeling that he'll get out
do well for
a little while and then crash and burn
do you have somebody who's walking
alongside you through this
yes okay so
um i'm just a guy on the radio
okay so i'm not gonna tell you what to
do
i'm gonna tell you what i would do in my
house
okay um nope i'm gonna tell you what i
would tell my sister
i'm gonna tell you what i would tell a
best friend of mine
who was a co-worker who was a woman in
the same situation
okay um
if you've got 11 month old in your house
somebody getting out of rehab whatever
that's supposed to mean for this
situation
after 28 days is not coming back to my
house for a season
okay i would tell my sister not to let
that happen i would tell my wife
um well i'm married to her so that'd be
weird but
um i i would tell the close friends of
mine in my life that are
married women with small kids that that
would not be a wise decision
um i would
in my opinion your church leadership has
proven themselves to be
not worth following i wouldn't go back
to that building
and i know that's hard and i know that
you've probably got deep relationships
there
but they let you down they let that
little girl down
they let that 13 year old girl down they
let her family down they let that
congregation down
and it's disgusting um but at the end of
the day i would not have somebody just
pop back into my house
without some very serious
couples counseling without somebody
walking alongside you both
a friend and a professional if not a
couple
and without a very very clear plan on
your part about what it's gonna look
like
to be well what it's gonna look like to
be welcomed back in this house
okay now if you've ever listened to this
show you know that i'm all about
redemption i think it's
deep and i think that there is not a
lost person
i also don't mess around with people who
hurt kids
i just don't and so
can you and him reconcile and can he
change his life i believe so i wouldn't
be sitting in this chair i wouldn't be
doing this job
is it going to be a hard messy ugly
bumpy road yes
can you all get a hole in that
congregation i don't think you can
um can you get a whole
just pop back in 28 days later i would
say almost no chance
do i know that that means that i'm
telling you that i would recommend to my
friend
that they have to be a single parent for
a season yeah i know and that
really is hard um
but what the most important thing you've
got to do here
is number one you got to kill this
fantasy right
it doesn't exist anymore as it once was
and the second thing you've got to do
is you've got to get somebody to walk
alongside you and make sure
you have on paper what
he's gonna have to do to earn the
privilege
to be your husband to earn the privilege
to parent that child in in proximity
because what happens is you have a
feeling like i'm just gonna
know and as you mentioned it's just
gonna kind of slowly slip back to the
way it was
right and you're gonna feel crazy and
um if he truly is an addict which who
knows man i'm not a psychologist
so i'm not going to say anything else
about that
there is some master manipulation going
on right
and there is some extraordinary
gaslighting there's some giftedness
in getting people to believe that um
you're the crazy one not them right
right any answer to why in the world
were you holding hands with my 13 year
old daughter other than
i screwed up bad and i'm i i
just screwed up not well you know i was
trying to live through a fantasy that i
had when i was a kid
anything other than that is somebody not
taking responsibility
um anyway i could harp on that all day
long all that to say is i want you
really
please amanda get with somebody get with
two people get with three people
who will sit down with you and really
craft
almost in stone what these boundaries
are gonna look like
someone who's gonna be able to say to
you out loud like i am now
what was is no more and any relationship
moving forward is something that y'all
are gonna have to recraft and rebuild
together
because it's all different after this
okay
okay it's different after this can it be
good i think so i do but does he have a
lot of work to do
yes and the final thing is this isn't to
you this is to anybody
leading any sort of organization with
kids
you can't have these tribunals where you
agree to this or i'm going to tell on
you
you can't bring in authorities
every time bring in
social workers and people to be with the
kids every time
investigate stuff make sure it's right
these little side deals this little
nonsense goes on and
on and on and the forest fire of this
trauma rages
on for generations stop it if you're a
church
if you're a school if you're a daycare
whatever you happen to be
you're a coach you signed up to have
kids in your presence
which means you signed up to protect
children
and a 28-day visit to nashville
is not gonna keep your kids safe cops
will
police officers will therapists will
social workers will
well i'm sorry amanda that wasn't
directed at you but here's the deal
that's okay here's the deal um
to everybody listening um a man is in a
situation where somebody has dropped a
bomb in her world
and amanda i'm heartbroken for you i
wish i had something else i could say
i'm heartbroken for you
and it's going to be a hard 20 21 for
you
um i'll be thinking about you i want you
to keep us posted
please please circle back shoot me an
email let me know how it goes
and to her husband if he happens to be
listening to this
you're not gonna weaponize this
situation you're not gonna go to war
with your wife you're not gonna be
dramatic you screwed
up you hurt a kid
you're not well and you got a long road
ahead of you
that's it man no song today i'm out
y'all uh
thanks for the call amanda thank you
everybody for calling i'm out
this has been the dr john dolone show
thank you so much
you